mais enfin la main sur le convoitée
marteau du président de la chambre mais
à quel prix
[Applaudissements]
c'était facile a-t-il lancé ironiquement
au terme d'une autre soirée de
déchirement en public après des
négociations dramatiques à même le
plancher de la chambre du brasse
camarade entre des élus républicains il
aura fallu des jours de chaos et 15
tours de vote au caucus républicain pour
couronner Kevin makertee donc
nous nous jugez pas à notre départ mais
à notre arrivée dimmakery les paroles
d'un élu au pied d'argile les troubles
fêtes de l'aile la plus à droite de son
parti lui ont soutirait d'énormes
concessions et seront mieux équipés pour
le faire chanter Kevin Maker ringera
avec une épée de Damoclès au-dessus de
la tête il leur a promis de modifier les
règles de la chambre un seul élu
pourrait désormais demander un vote pour
le relevé de ses fonctions
des membres du fameux cocus de la
liberté siégeront à des comités
importants et leur volonté seront
priorisées comme le contrôle des
dépenses de quoi compliquer les
négociations pour relever le plafond de
la dette américaine et bonifiez l'aide à
l'Ukraine par exemple en attendant les
prochaines batailles que veulent mes
quartiers a tenu à remercier un allié
personne ne devrait douter de
l'influence de Donald Trump dit-il ce
dernier aurait fait des appels pour
l'aider à se faire élire 2 ans presque
jour pour jour après l'assaut du
Capitole l'ombre de l'ancien président
plane toujours sur un parti profondément
divisé après le désordre des derniers
jours ce stratège républicain
s'impatiente
pour affronter les démocrates en 2024 il
faudra de l'unité rappelle-t-il
combien de temps avant que le caucus
républicain ne se déchire de nouveau
[Applaudissements]
même si pour lui le plus difficile est à
venir ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada
Washington